last year it was MLB tonight that beat
us this this year it was pardon the
interruption Michael Wilbon is kind
enough to join us I know he's busy
probably prepping for his half hour
pardon the interruption tonight so you
got to be exhausted and Michael joins us
now good morning Michael congratulations
no a lot no not a little in line and
then we're saying we've already done
twice as much work in an hour as you've
done I mean maybe not as good of work as
you'll do on pardon the interruption
tonight but your 30 minutes we've
already done an hour on this show we're
headed to shoot around maybe did you
celebrate last night no no great that
you were there Dan no I'm in Toronto I
will tell you this I did go I walked
into you know restaurant bar whatever
here in sir I see it was Gretzky's I
should probably say that walk didn't the
Gretzky's here in Toronto and Charles
Wade Berkeley and a Google people where
they were watching a game and Charles I
propose a toast to like half the bar and
everybody toasted and that was very kind
of them Charles has how many Emmy Awards
do you have there I have five see okay
Charles we've got to have what eight or
nine yeah maybe yeah maybe so I thought
it was great that Charles did that sit
right up in the bar and at that moment I
don't know in about an hour
I dunno look you'll be well enough it's
great I am honored I am thankful but I
don't I don't pay attention of these
things going in I didn't even know the
state of the awards dinner or whatever
it is
thank you I'm not sure what formative I
no that was last night I started my
cellphone started just going crazy it
blew up and my first thought is please
don't let this be a news story and I got
a you know run to it how many of you
that's my first thought how many of me
says pardon the interruption huh three
that was add only the third and the only
great wearing how did how did pardon the
interruption start Marcia Pierrot was
doing sports century and he we were
telling you now or two with the
panelists the sports writers who were
floating on all those people that's best
athletes the best the best that of the
20th century and Shapiro would come and
visit us at the Washington Post as he
Tony and me doing what we do now just
across a hallway as we sat in our
respective offices as your para was
really young old now but he was really
young he was in his late 20s and he said
I remember him saying you know if I ever
become anything at the network in terms
of stature and decision-making I'm gonna
put this on television and Tony was like
right can you get me with a cup of
coffee and shut up please and Shapiro
wasn't one she became somebody that
could do this the first call he called
me I was at the NBA Finals in Los
Angeles Joe's not long ago that was
Finals in Los Angeles in 2001 and he
said we got to have dinner tomorrow
night
I said why he said because I've been
named whatever the title is you know
star of programming and my first duty is
gonna be to put you guys on television
and I said you're second dude he's gonna
be fired this is not sound listen sound
like sound thinking to me that's not it
I heard that Kornheiser almost didn't do
it well neither one both of us almost
didn't do it Ari I remember one day I
was much closer to not doing it and Tony
okay I mean all these all these stories
tend to revolve around Tony because it's
sexier and he's more eccentric but I I
was in place Tony being 10 years older
he'd written economy done all that he'd
done it for a long time he was he didn't
want I didn't want to travel and go to
games and
the thing the columnist need to do back
then and the you know late 19th and
early 20th century and erode I'm sorry
late 20th and early 21st he didn't want
to do that stuff and I did and so I
don't want to be in a studio every day
not going to games and and you know Here
I am in Toronto as we as we speak I
still do that that was an assistance on
my behalf but then we walked into our
studio or newsroom and there were people
there who would move from Bristol and
move from places and we're like why are
you people here and I said well we did a
television show we intend to start on
like October 10th and we're like
seriously we haven't signed anything and
neither one of us had and and we were
not prepped to do it and I want to sound
ungrateful because again I'm grateful
but we will I had the dream job of my
life back then being a columnist for The
Washington Post and Toni and so we were
not you know moved that we had to do
this immediately and there were people
in our lives who said thankfully I shut
up
and a listen this is going to be
different Charles Charles Brockden is
one of them and they were sitting with
Charles need said are you crazy you know
you got to do this you guys this was
going to be good it's going to matter
and there were people like that in both
of our lives and so we we said okay
maybe it's time to listen and shut up he
said Michael Wilbon pardon the
interruption and in Toronto Game four
coming up tonight with the Bucks
and those Raptors the Warriors ability
to come back here and do it in four
games you don't have boogie you don't
have ego dalla and you don't have Kevin
Durant that's pretty impressive to do it
and beat a good Portland team and do it
I think in three of the four games Mike
they were down by at least 15 points
what do you make of this run by the
Warriors I think it's an all-time great
run I think it measures up to anything I
think and I'm too young to have seen I
saw the end of the Russell Celtics the
very end I remember the last
championship but not much more than that
but obviously we know the history of it
and this then and we obviously we're
talking more teens more resources you
know it's not every team is a pigeon
waiting to be taken advantage of by Red
Auerbach
but I mean at the point we are now in
this culture of sport for the Warriors
to do this with all of their assets
available is just stunning and to do it
without Kevin Durant and I if you can
say okay without booking presents too
but is this about Durant man and I
understand they haven't beaten a great
team yet in this run but you know the
Celtics didn't always be great teams and
Russell's run every time they usually it
to be won at the end of it is often had
Wilt Chamberlain on it whether it was
the conference final or the final so men
I mean we're reminded how great Steph
Curry is I don't know why we needed
reason I know we did most people did and
you know I was at the Houston series I
told the deaf series and you know Game
five when when when Durant goes out I'm
thinking okay there's no way they're
gonna win Game five and of course he
went Game five and I'm and I thought the
Warriors could and perhaps would win
Game seven but the go to Houston and and
and and played that way and I'm tired of
dumping on Houston and I decided this
that night you know we don't dump on
Malone in Stockton we don't dump on
Patrick Ewing we don't dump on Reggie
Miller you know we don't dump on who am
i leaving out from that great periods of
time where those guys all lost Jordan
Barkley him Olajuwon we don't dump on
them yeah we don't say they choked we
don't say they were Jagger's and I'm not
going to say that about Harden and Chris
Paul they're not as good as the Warriors
that's what I'm prepared to say the
Warriors are great and these other teams
are beating a really good really really
good but they're not great like the
Warriors are great and so I I've now
refocused and to me it's just time to
credit those guys and get off of dumping
on people for what they're not what
happened with the Lakers yesterday I
don't know and the more people I talk to
and here in Toronto everybody's here and
last week everybody was in Chicago
because the the the draft lottery and
then the combine and people were
commuting up to Milwaukee and like the
whole industry was sitting around and
nobody had any answers I mean the
smartest people the people of
longest-tenured nobody
the answers it's a mess it's a mess and
the surprise is fear of men but we've
seen other great franchises become a
mess I mean notably the Raiders it
didn't happen all the time it doesn't
happen for a minute in six years this is
not just a down cycle this is a mess but
like what happened I mean it's a failure
of a whole bunch of people and a failure
of an institution to sort of keep people
moving in the same direction I mean
that's a lot of that and I don't know
how they get out of it like this is not
just about going out signing a couple of
free agents and putting them on the
court I don't believe that so I think
there's a bigger mess in that what the
Lakers and I know how to get it fixed
yeah I was surprised magic went scorched
earth with a franchise that he loves so
much that you may not like Rob polenka
but you can't do that to the Lakers and
I know that he wants to entertain and
first take did a great job in asking the
right questions but I I was disappointed
I was sad when I I was hearing Magic say
what he was I'm you know part of me was
like hey it makes my job easier when he
says things like this but then there's a
party that you want to protect these
icons from themselves sometimes and just
say you know don't do that like you're
bigger than Rob polenka you know ok
backstabbed you alright but you don't
want you could have gone to genie and
said look you've got to make a decision
here Genie for the betterment of this
franchise we have to be on the same page
and we're not and in whatever she
decides that but there's no leadership
there Mike I think that's not really
what I take away is I need a leader
there and you got to get a leader in
there pretty quickly I don't know that
he didn't do that I mean it sounds like
these things that have been going on
involving
pálinka to whatever degree in magic it
sounds like I mean that was that was
going on when people weren't necessarily
paying attention yeah and I don't know
what conversation he had and didn't have
a genie yeah yeah it's impossible to
escape that conclusion right now about
what they don't have
and camp Aleta who is in that position
right now can he do that like like in
talking again talking to all these
people in the industry and it's now
we're going to broaden this out and talk
about agents and players and 380 people
representing three agents like Jim Poole
in to lead them can he lead the monitors
can he lead them through a summer which
is going to be the most tumultuous
summer that the NBA perhaps has ever
seen it certainly could be wilder than
2010 and 16 and those are crazy summers
yeah let's okay do that but do you
believe the Jason Kidd part of the
reason why he was brought in and this is
there's a report that he was brought in
to be an assistant head coach because of
his relationship with the Greek freak
that he could somehow convince him in a
couple of years I don't know Jason
Kidd's gonna be in the position in a
couple of years but that you bring the
Greek freak he's already said he doesn't
like in LA and he doesn't like Miami
doesn't like the big cities he's
comfortable there and you're gonna
possibly hire Jason Kidd because of his
relationship with a Greek freak I mean
part of the reason the Wizards hired
Scott Brooks was Costa Mia proved
himself as a good coach you can either
Scott Brooks having nothing to do with
his previous stop which was of course
Oklahoma City but part of the reason the
Wizards win five years no no five years
35 million dollars was that he was going
to get them in with Kevin Durant Kevin
Durant didn't even meet with the Wizards
it's like it's like the Jay Z factor
remember when Jay Z was a part owner of
the nets and was like all people are
gonna want to play with Jay Z the Jay Z
factor nobody went to play for the nets
because of Jay Z know how desperate
people are to get that big star to get
that one player who disproportionately
impacts the game
tilts the board yeah it shows you that
that sport this the NBA more than any of
us for you wouldn't do that in pro
football you're not going to do that and
we've seen things win without doing that
in the NBA teams haven't won without
getting that play
except for like the 2004 pistons you
know they had an ensemble without an
all-time great player you know probably
I mean I guess almost certainly without
a top 50 player and I say that with
apologies Chauncey Billups who I loved
and loved as a player but the baptistin
team is like the only team that doesn't
have that yeah so yes people are willing
to go to preposterous lengths to try and
guarantee that they get the player who
has the ultimate impact on the game and
now they look and projecting that onto
the kupo is one of those four or five
Mike it's good to visit with you glad to
see you putting in a little extra work
than just a half hour on and don't be
afraid to mail it in this year so we can
win next Jimmy give us a chance Mike
about you know I said who influenced us
and who said hey stop there in your head
and just think about writing a column
and do this show the absence of another
one on the mantle is if you need one you
and I talked back then and I remember
said are you crazy
wait Mike sorry so we won the emmy last
night we won the Emmy I'll put your name
on it like the Stanley Cup do I'm good
with that I'm Mike thank you I
appreciate that all of a sudden all of a
sudden the day got a little brighter
thank you again congratulations I'm sure
it made mr. Tony almost smile thank you
Mike that said Michael Wilbon for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]